SPEAKER: Health care
organizations are increasingly
using cloud platforms to
personalize care, analyze
large data sets, enhance
research and development,
optimize operational costs,
and increase their security
and privacy.
And with HIPAA's privacy
rule, health care entities
are also tasked to safeguard
protected health information.
Google has partnered with
many health care organizations
over the years and has
consolidated multiple best
practices into a single solution
called a Healthcare Data
Engine, a.k.a.
HDE, which is aimed at
assisting cloud infrastructure
or security engineers set up
a data management layer that
is automated; offer
pre-configured data maps
and pipelines to
help data engineers
and clinical informaticists
spend less time on things
like manual data
transformation processes,
real-time risk scores,
and insights optimized
for longitudinal
patient records;
and has traceability
built in order
to know where data came from
and how it was processed,
how and why data
exists where it is.
This is known as provenance.
Setting up your data
environment and designing it
for repeatable deployments
in a highly-regulated sector
can be challenging.
HDE offers a pre-built
configuration script
that serves as a template
to help build out your cloud
resources with all the necessary
parameters and governance
design.
It uses a Terraform, which
is a familiar open source way
to define and provide data
center infrastructure using
a declarative
configuration language.
When projects are
deployed successfully,
the script will
write a YAML file
with all generated
fields specified
in the project's config using
the generated fields path
attribute.
These fields are used to
generate monitoring rules.
Overall, Healthcare Data
Engine's implementation
automates the following for key
dev, staging, and production
environments.
The creation of a
Google Cloud folder
and multiple cloud
projects, provisions
the necessary resources
for common health care data
use cases, as well as the
access rules to manage each.
It establishes a
collection of audit locks,
enables cloud monitoring
metrics and alerts,
and allows users to
create visualizations
to track your resources
and security policies.
And if an organization uses
an on-premise or third-party
identity platform, you can
synchronize this user directory
with Cloud Identity,
as well as set up
SAML 2.0 based single sign on
to let users access Google Cloud
or any work app by signing
in once and accessing
all their services.
Next, from an information
harmonization perspective,
data engineers have a dedicated,
fully-managed Jupyter lab web
app running on Google Cloud
AI platform notebooks.
That enables them to
convert HL7v2 messages
and proprietary data schemas
that are in CSV into FHIR.
This notebook interface serves
as an integrated development
tool, because it includes
operations such as syntax
highlighting, auto-completion
of functions, version control,
integration with git, and a
code source repo, et cetera.
And because it is connected to
your Google Cloud resources,
it can execute distributed
data processing pipelines
on Dataflow.
Dataflow is a fully-managed
streaming analytics service
that minimizes latency,
processing time,
and cost through auto
scaling and batch processing.
This is the Jupyter
Lab IDE UI in HDE.
We will open Big Query
here on the side,
thanks to the UI plugin.
We now have a list of
tables listed inside
of a Big Query data set
provisioned through the HDE
process.
These tables have been
pre-ingested with raw CSV data.
Let's take a look at them.
Note that our goal is to
convert this CSV patient
data into a FHIR JSON resource.
Next, let's look at
our local file system.
These are prepackaged
sample mapping files.
They are part of
HDE's Jupyter Lab IDE.
This one specifically
converts CSV data to FHIR.
Now let's visit Git.
To the Jupyter Demo branch,
and open the following file.
Now from this notebook, we
will execute these commands
in Python code, then we will
run this prebuilt magic command.
When it's done, we visit the
JSON that has been generated.
Next, we run a validation
test to our FHIR resource
and find an error saying that
the patient given name is
expected to be an array.
So we will modify the code
responsible for patient data
by converting it to an array
and rerun the magic command
and reload the JSON.
And now we have it
validated as successful,
because it is now valid FHIR.
After this step, we
perform test mapping,
which executes the
data transformation
code into a Dataflow pipeline.
This link brings you to
the Dataflow pipeline.
And finally, we return to
Git and look at the changes,
and then commit them.
Data engineers also
need traceability
of how data is
transformed and created.
They need to debug data
issues and understand which
pipeline produced what data.
This is commonly referred
to as provenance.
Provenance data gets written
to Google Cloud Storage
by the various pipelines for
ingestion, harmonization,
or reconciliation.
A cron job using Cloud Scheduler
runs a processing pipeline
that takes this provenance
data and writes it
to an operational FHIR store.
Provenance links device to
input and outputs, document
references, and FHIR resources.
For example, let's
figure out how
a sample patient got created
into the FHIR file store.
By looking at the JSON,
we see several attributes.
An important one
is the ID field,
which can help us understand the
provenance of the patient data.
Let's visit the
operational FHIR store
and look at the
provenance record
by using the filterable
lookup of the patient ID.
As we locate it, we can
investigate in the Elements tab
the additional fields
tied to that record.
The provenance record combines
the source information, as well
as the data of the
pipeline that transformed
the source into the target,
as well as the target that
created the source.
For example, I can see
there are 19 resources that
were created in conjunction
with the patient.
Some are organizational, device,
location, or message resources.
As for the pipeline
itself, it exists
as a device resource under
the Agent field, then "who."
In order for me to figure
out the message itself,
which HL7v2 message was
the source for the data,
I can go to the
entity, what field,
and here I have a
document reference that
points to the HL7v2 message.
Let me click into it and
show you how it's structured.
When I click Content,
Attachment, URL,
I have a pointer to the
message in the HL7v2 store.
And if I were to do
a cURL Get request,
I would retrieve
the full message.
And that is an overview of
how provenance works in HDE.
And there you have
it, a quick summary
on how you can enable
infrastructure and data
specialists via the
Healthcare Data Engine, which
is a predefined
configuration to get you
started with the necessary
Cloud infrastructure
and data transformations
with built-in auditability.
To get started with some of
the underlying technology
that powers HDE, you will need
to have a Google Cloud project.
If you do not have one, I have
included a link to a trial
account with free credits
in this video's description,
along with other
helpful resources.
And community, if you
found this episode helpful,
please subscribe to the
channel to get notifications
of more health care episodes.
Cheers.